you did a bunch of programming
competitions
what was your interest your love for
programming
what did you learn to that experience
especially now that
as much of your work has taken a long
journey through mathematics
i think i always was amazed by how
computers
could do things fast if i wanted to make
it an abstract
analysis of why it is that i saw some
power in the computer
because if the computer can do things so
many times faster than humans
where the hard part is telling the
computer what to do and how to do it
if you can master that asking the
computer what to do
then you could conceivably achieve more
things and those contests i was in
those were the opposite in some sense of
making a complete
product like a game as a product those
contests were
effectively write a function to do
something extremely efficiently
and if you are able to do that then you
can unlock more of the power of the
computer
but also doing it quickly there's a time
element from the human perspective to to
be able to
program quickly there's something nice
so there's like almost like an athletics
component
to where you're almost like uh an
athlete
seeking optimal performance as a human
being trying to write these programs
and at the same time it's kind of art
because you're
the best way to write a program quickly
is to write a simple program
you used to have a damn good solution so
it's not necessary you have to type fast
you have to think through a really clean
beautiful
uh solution i mean
what do you think is the use of those
programming competitions do you think
they're ultimately something you would
recommend for students for people
interested in programming or people
interested in building stuff
yes i think so because especially with
the work that i've been doing nowadays
even trying to control covid something
that was very helpful from day one
was understanding that the kinds of
computations we would want to do
we could conceivably do on like a four
core cloud machine on amazon web
services
out to a population which might have
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people
the reason why that was important to
have that back of the envelope
calculation with efficient algorithms
is because if we couldn't do that then
we would bankrupt ourselves before we
could get to a big enough skill
if you think about how you grow anything
from small to big
if in order to grow it from small to big
you also already need 10 000 cloud
servers
you'll never get too big and also
the nice thing about programming
competitions is that you actually build
a thing that uh works so you uh you
finish it
there's a completion thing and you
realize i think there's a magic to it
where you realize that it's not so hard
to build
something that works to have a system
that uh
successfully takes in inputs and
produces outputs and solves a difficult
problem
and that directly transfers to building
a startup essentially that can help
some aspect of this world as long as
it's mostly be
based on software engineering things get
really tricky when you have to
manufacture stuff
that's why people like elon musk are so
impressive that they it's not just
software
tesla autopilot is just not just
software it's it's like you have to
actually
like have factories that build uh cars
and there's like a million components
in involved in in the machinery required
to assemble those cards and so on
but in software one person can change
the world which is
incredible
you